Does a daily order of detoxine protocols matter?
Good question.
Exercise a new lymph massage, a new rebound, a new sauna to the coffee end of us.
Is there an issue with what order you do them in?
Just whatever order makes sense for you and your lifestyle?
Yeah, does it make sense to be exercising and go with a sauna?
Maybe that doesn't make sense because you're burning off a lot of minerals and then you're going into sauna.
So it's kind of doing similar things.
Exercise in sauna is doing a coffee in them and then doing a castoral pack.
You know, right after that, a good thing to do.
I don't know, it makes it kind of you're doing similar things there.
So breaking them up, you just kind of got to think through some things.
I don't think there's any perfect order for anybody or anything of these, you know.
So it's just to be, you just try to use your common sense of those things.
But using castoral packs on my deck and liver overnight, is it's a good thing or is it too long?
Typically, we recommend castoral packs doing that like 30 minutes, doing it overnight.
I know people have done it.
We've had people, you know, maybe on this call that have done it or on this video, not on a call.
But, yeah, if you're not having ill effects of it, I don't think there's a problem with it.